we're shirt that's in to move whatever
video you're watching you're trying too
hard yeah that's what that is I'm trying
too hard or maybe I'm just wearing a
shirt that fits the video oh god it's a
it's some try way too hard what's going
on reject nation I'm Greg Alba Humphrey
I don't know if you guys have been
following this or heard the news but
Eminem released a new album about a week
or two would go called kamikaze I did a
one-minute Instagram or view on it
because I had her I listened to the
whole thing when I was working out quick
thoughts on that whole album just get
out of the way I heard like a couple of
songs without listening to the album and
I liked them but then there was a couple
I was like I really care for it but
listen to the entire album as a whole
from beginning and starting with the
ring or ending with the fence I really
loved I loved the hell out of this album
and of course you know the not alike
song going against MGK and then MGK did
his rap devil song which I actually
commit I like that song mmm is my hero
favorite solo artist of all time and I
thought was a good song but I've been
waiting for this track you know I'm like
we don't really do music video reactions
on YouTube this isn't really our brand
here you know let Shawn see and I'm
Dante the people who really cover music
videos and songs and all that do that I
was like you know what every day I've
been checking the Eminem music channel
for when's this track drop this is a big
reason why we don't really do some
reactions at all that is because we
always go through hell the processes try
to at least get it uploaded on YouTube
and be visible because most of them like
a 99% of them are not monetized which is
fair but usually they get blocked right
away so we have to go this whole process
to at least go to be visible on the
internet for the guys who really want to
see their
and a lot of disputing and all that so
we're gonna borrow from Sean C and I'm
Dante and a lot of people who do music
video reactions and song reactions so we
won't play the whole song little pause
every now and again and talk about it
dude either just talk about see you
ready here as we watch mmm destroy
Machine Gun Kelly what if he doesn't
know I don't even know MGK was until I
heard the rap I'm like who is Machine
Gun Kelly now he's more popular than
ever
yeah it goes in line with that ringer
song of him talking about when he talks
about someone yeah I mean I heard a
couple of his verses and maybe a song or
yeah up until this point but I'm not
really a big MGK aficionado by any
stretch yeah sure MGK is like way better
rapper then myself or any of my friends
hidden play a possum is way too early
that opening line about of MGK drive
devil song when he does start insulting
the beard my first thought was mmm
blame insult me personally I dig
Eminem's beard but then again we're
bearded gentleman yeah it's not a
particularly hard bar out things yeah
whatever em leave his beard alone
he's not on the ground for you Donna I'm
gonna start
I mean just hearing that I really love
this so far insult me aniline compliment
me on the next so true yeah cuz there
were times at the rat devil song where I
was like wait a minute
is he admiring Eminem right is he going
full-on diss mode right now or is he
kind of trying to play some game here
yeah I mean of course this he goes later
into this song like okay he's on full on
this vote but I like half this part of
the verses him reacting to are you
insulting me you're complimenting me
what are you doing exactly and I love
his comebacks because a lot of a lot of
that disk was dedicated to your old now
mmm yeah it's funny to see him directly
address that early on cuz I was listen
to the dead-end hip-hop breakdown and
that was one of their main complaints
about MGK song is like for the first two
thirds it's mostly like your short your
old your beard looks weird yeah very be
a petty insults and stuff yeah but I'm
like but that has nothing to do with his
skill at all yeah he can't attack him on
his skill or his quality as a person you
know exactly exactly but I love that
idea of like yeah but when I was your
age I was doing better than you you're
[ __ ] Mountain now but make a molehill
out of you I think free savage bar no
good play on the play on words
weenies the Cheerios because I'm taking
the [ __ ] in him Kelly I need reading
material dictionary oh shoot that was
three pounds of gold what do you know
I like that bar got the do case hold a
shoot the video just [ __ ] did your
gravies like walking around with that
shovel take the video twister because I
think there was the the general fan
response of machine gun Kelly's track
this is good there's some good lines in
here but uh we all know mm gonna come
back yeah
why am i bad at one of the common boxes
at people like he's just digging his own
grave with that shovel isn't he yeah
Kelly has a big fan base without a death
like a huge fan base but I was on that
spectrum of I don't know who Machine Gun
Kelly is I've never even heard one of
his songs and like this disc this whole
back and forth has made him more famous
and he could have ever hoped for
and him dissing Eminem becomes one of
his most reputable things in his biggest
tracks and now everything's taking him
down I was a great looking line he's
acknowledging everything we wanted him
to acknowledge gotta hit the key points
main cuz he makes that line about
Eminem's height doesn't matter how tall
I am I to be sure than this and you'd
still have to look up so much the
climber Ridge up to me the machine gun I
would never want to be dis by a minute
no no if I was displaying they've take
you apart in ways you didn't realize
could happen if Eminem made a diss track
about me I would come back with a very
lengthy detailed apology track to that
diss track and to actually that
distracting oh just go uh-huh
yeah totally agree you were not at a
line at all yep [ __ ] all my family sure
[Music]
you know I love you say there may be a
couple illusions at the end there that
quite catch although he did drop a nice
little gez barb in there cuz a lot of
the talk about Machine Gun Kelly is that
jeez he kind of swiped his lane and you
know up when MGK was kind of on the
track to do so I actually think this was
the perfect appropriate amount yeah
because you know people have really been
anticipating this and there's been a lot
of hype come let's come back but there's
a three part interview that you could
watch Eminem and suede and he spends
like five minutes talking about this
whole MGK situation technology and how
like if Eminem had to keep doing diss
tracks back against everyone he's
insulted or made a line about and every
one of his albums even in just the
Kamikaze one he'd spend years dedicated
to this and like I love his attitude
here cuz MGK seemed like he was really
offended and MGK were like you know he
did a whole rap devil song the way
Eminem handles it it sounds like I'm
just gonna take one crap hey I don't
know how much Eminem rewrote this and
worked his ass off on it or whatever but
the way he handled it here really had
that I don't give a [ __ ] attitude let's
go over the [ __ ] you said about me and
say how you're like stupid or wrong yeah
because Eminem couldn't take the
approach of like whoa you really got to
be yeah it's just you know people want
me to come back with this and you're
gonna attack me now I'm involved this
but all right here we go yeah it's the
game I mean that's the other thing too
is that's some of the discussion I've
heard as well as like you know people
have given MGK props for coming back
with a song cuz a lot of the dudes who
Eminem he talked about on kamikaze
basically just said [ __ ] on social media
but you know this is the game you know
is going back and forth at each other
this is kind of like part at least of
the life's blood of the genre yeah and
to see a beef like this grab everybody's
attention for a minute kind of seems
like a special moment yeah you know also
Lafayette menem's been pretty vocal
about attacking auto-tune yeah I mean
you know there's a lack of authenticity
to it
you know sometimes you can work I don't
know I personally have never really been
a fan of auto-tune well auto-tune is I
don't know it's like anything else it's
like at first yeah it's like it winning
today abuse though yeah totally it's
something that like everybody would put
over there singing and it got really
annoying for a while but in truth like
it's just another affect you know it's
just another thing to add to your
repertoire like a distortion pedal or
anything else the game has changed and
the new genres that are prevalent are
very different from you know lyrical
hip-hop most definitely I know he hates
mumble rap and things like that and I
guess I don't blame him I'm not as big
on the most cutting edge you know
hip-hop or whatever but I do really
appreciate this song and that lasts long
just cuz you look at the mirror I think
that you're Marshall because that yet
the blond hair earrings a lot of this
dis is like no matter what you say
you're just in my shadow you know and
now that you've got an even bigger
reputation off of dissing me you're just
more in my shadow now you know yeah like
I said I like the rap devil song for
what it is and yeah I know we can rap
better than anyone I've ever met in my
life
yes all right beau that being said the
fact that he kind of does have one flow
throughout and Eminem still mixes it up
here too which I really appreciate like
it's a big part of what makes Eminem
specialist his ability to really mix it
up oh yeah I mean Eminem is always
trying to kind of shape-shift you know
every set I feel like he's not content
to stay within one flow for too many
bars yeah it just seems like he's got to
jump around and and and that's just a
stylistic difference ultimately to me
but yeah I wonder how I'm GK's gonna
take this I feel like either way this
works for him he's not gonna have the
biggest career ever after this but he's
definitely got more fans that he did
before yeah yeah this is just like
Eminem working out you know there's
really no benefit for Eminem to do this
yeah but a bit of benefits ng
okay can we load the comments yet are
they still just completely finally ours
we I've been trying to at least see the
comments this is our first time hearing
it but there's been so many comments
dropping thousands of new comments every
time that if we have been able to seen
it there's so many comments coming in
YouTube can't keep up when we started
playing this it was at 4 million views
we refreshed it and now it's at 5
million seven hundred ten thousand views
mmm
and for a fan perspective it's just a
fun thing to witness you know yeah I
remembers one of my heroes always loved
the guy I love the Kamikaze album and
yeah this is just a nice little nice
little distal light that a shady closes
out John sure you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell it's getting updated every time a
review or video is out why would the
subscribe button do what this subscribes
wasn't supposed to do we have a patreon
come check us out over there we got
full-length TV show reactions the
occasional music video reactions in full
great community over there weekly Q&A is
a lot of fun stuff come check us out
over there and we'll catch you on the
next one and I forgot anything to I do
good all right Cheers people be well